hello AP Calculus students this is Sal
Khan of the Khan Academy and as we all
know the AP Calculus exams both the a b
and b c exams are coming up this
thursday May fifth and i'm sure you are
buzzing with as much excitement as i am
and in case you didn't already realize
it Khan Academy has a lot of resources
for you in calculus you can either jump
in and learn the things that you want to
learn or we have what we call our
missions where it'll guide you through
all the calculus that you learn for
either the a B or the BC exams but on
top of that in preparation for this
super exciting exam on Monday May second
we are going to have live office hours
and so from 4 to 5 p.m. pacific standard
time it will be myself and grant who is
our calculus fellow and we will be
answering your questions about calculus
it could be reviewing things it will be
going through example problems or we
might point you to the right resources
on Khan Academy itself and so show up
it's going to be a lot of fun you do not
want to miss out on this and anything
that you want us to cover go to the
Facebook post about this live stream
that we're going to have on facebook on
Monday May second and put your questions
tell us what you want to cut what you
want us to cover what you're confused
about or any example problems that you
want to see